president Trump is using his powers to
give clemency to nearly a dozen people
including high-profile white-collar
criminals among them is disgraced former
Illinois governor Rod Blagojevich who
was out of prison this morning he was
set free when President Trump commuted
his sentence last night the president
pardoned former junk bond King Michael
Milken and former NFL owner Eddie
DeBartolo jr. they were all convicted of
charges that included fraud corruption
and lying
Paula Reid is at the White House with
more on this story so Paula what's the
backstory here why did the president do
it good morning Gail the president says
he is relying on personal
recommendations when deciding where to
apply his vast pardon power now the
Justice Department has a formal vetting
process for pardoned petitions and the
president's unusual approach is raising
concerns that in this administration
clemency is mostly going to those with
connections everlasting gratitude to
President Trump for for doing what he
did the former Democratic governor of
Illinois Liguria thanked the president
and maintained his innocence rod
Blagojevich was convicted in 2011 of
trying to sell then President Barack
Obama's vacated Senate seat and was
sentenced to 14 years in prison he
served eight years in jail there's a
long time to go many people disagree
with the sentence the president's
decision prompted Swift backlash from
the prosecutors on the case who said a
justice system must hold public
officials accountable for corruption
blow guy ovitch was a contestant on
Celebrity Apprentice but President Trump
said what got his attention was
Blagojevich his wife pleading his case
on Fox News a corruption of my husband's
trial also seen on the network former
New York City police commissioner
Bernard Kerik who is convicted of tax
fraud and lying to the government just
Monday Carrick argued New York should be
tougher on criminals we're going back to
where we were in 1990s early 1990s 1980s
and and it shouldn't be President Obama
granted clemency to more than 1,900
people more than any other president but
over 1,600 of them
were nonviolent drug offenders most of
whom had received mandatory minimum
sentences NFL star Derrick Brooks who
praised the pardon of former San
Francisco 49ers owner Edward DeBartolo
jr. defended the president against
allegations he's only pardoning those
with connections that's not about a
status in society that's the status
about someone that has a willing heart
in a desire to give something back to
someone else
president Trump will not say if he will
grant a pardon to his longtime friend
Roger stone who is scheduled to be
sentenced tomorrow after being convicted
of seven felonies Tony will Paul on that
subject there have been reports that
Attorney General Bill Barr has
threatened to resign over the
president's tweets regarding stone what
can you tell us about that
Tony CBS News has learned that the
Attorney General has told people he's
considered quitting over the president's
tweets but president Trump has a long
history of pressuring his own Justice
Department on Twitter he called former
attorney general Jeff Sessions unfair
beleaguered and even disgraceful on
Twitter so Barr was on notice that these
Twitter attacks are part of the job
and this really appears to be part of an
effort to put distance between the
Attorney General and the president amid
these increasing concerns about
political influence over the Justice
Department last night a Justice
Department spokeswoman though said Barr
has no plans to resign Tony for now
anyway Paula thank you very much